what are we going to do
go through every single ethnicity gender
sexuality and remake all the stories
with characters
that fit every single check box
how important is it for audiences to see
themselves
in the characters they see on screen
how important is it for audiences to see
themselves
i
i think they should see themselves in
whoever the protagonist is
but i think the thing that people
confuse is that that that uh person
should look like you
i there are so many times i've seen
movies where i identified with a
character who wasn't my age wasn't my
gender wasn't my ethnicity and i think
we live at a time now where
people are so narcissistic they look at
movies like video games
when
whereas in a video game you can actually
design for many games design a character
that looks like you that looks almost
exactly like you for certain video games
for movies
i think what people are talking about is
representation i think i do believe that
representation is something that is
important it's it's important to have
uh
you know
different types of people represented
within a story where possible but if you
are only capable of identifying with a
character who looks mostly like you i
would say that you're a narcissist and i
think that you
you
would benefit greatly
from identifying with characters who
don't look like you and quite frankly i
tend to gravitate towards stories where
i mean look i spend all day with myself
i don't want a story about me
i'd like to see a story about a
character that takes me to a different
place
that is experiencing different
challenges in life that i may never have
faced so that i can
safely experience that story through
through them
and
they don't have to look like me i think
that there's been an
over emphasis
put on that that there needs to be
characters that look just like you well
what are we gonna do
go through every single ethnicity gender
sexuality and remake all the stories
with characters
that fit every single checkbox
i think that just gets
exhausting
i think it gets exhausting and i i
really actually tend to gravitate
towards stories in particular world
cinema you know i grew up watching a lot
of asian cinema as a kid
and
i loved it it was an opportunity to
explore another culture you know um
you're going to think this is crazy but
i saw a movie called godzilla's revenge
when i was a kid and i uh godzilla's in
the movie
and is a hero to a young boy
and he has these
fantasies in his head about godzilla and
befriending godzilla's son menia
and within that story with this little
child which is around the same age as me
but not the same ethnicity
he was japanese and
but it was interesting to see how he he
ate you know you know these different
experiences in the culture were very
different and i found that just
really fun i connected it with him
because he was my same age it really
mattered very little to me that i looked
like
the the kid in that movie so i think
you're missing a huge opportunity to
experience
the world differently
through someone else's eyes i think
that's the whole and i've said this
before it's the purpose of all fiction
comic books movies video games novels
to see the world through the eyes of
someone else
and and movies give us an opportunity to
do that and if you're
wholly obsessed with a character's got
to be like you
go play a video game design a character
that looks just like you and go play
that video game but you're missing an
opportunity
certainly when it comes to comes to
movies
is there a healthy aspect
of narcissism in cinema i mean imagine
you go through life never seeing
yourself in a film or never seeing
yourself in magazines and then finally
now
you're seeing people that look like you
that have gone through the same thing
yeah now here here's
here's a caveat to that i would say that
you know
it's
i think it is important to have
different types of people represented
but help me to identify with that person
with their plight their story their
challenges
their struggles
you know i think this
[Music]
it's it's a challenge i would lay out
there to independent filmmakers right
have an audience identify with a
character that
where the majority of people will
identify with someone who isn't them
tell their story i get involved in the
story and the challenges for that
character i don't necessarily tend to
focus so much on
on uh you know who the person is from
their you know
outward traits right i mean one of my
heroes growing up was the character
ripley
from alien uh
that one is brought up quite a bit
sigourney weaver is so great i mean
even even in the
even in the episodes or the the the
sequels in you know the alien movies
that are not that great
she's always great sigourney weaver
always seems to deliver
and you know i saw that when i was a kid
wasn't her age wasn't i you know
i was not a woman
uh
and you know like i still identified
with her mainly because i thought she
was the smartest person
the other thing people forget about the
first alien movie
i mean there's a book about this save
the cat right she went back and saved
jonesy the cat
and i think that that that was one of
the things that and this happens late in
the movie right
so
obviously she has a relationship with
this cat jonesy
and identified with that because you
know what i have a cat
you know at the time i had a cat i
pretty much have always had cats so
or you know
it just i i think that that's an easy
way to identify
what is self-insert a self-insert in a
movie is when someone will literally
take themselves and just make them the
hero of the story
and
i i i find that to be kind of
off-putting
we we've seen it happen uh it happens
it's happening now with more frequency
where you see
you
you see a move and you're like okay well
that's
interesting who that person is and then
when you find out the backgrounds of the
creators it tends to just be almost
exactly like them down to even some
physical attributes and i'll say that
many are guilty of this
if you look at the work of
works of say david cronenberg or even
david lynch
kyle mclaughlin is pretty much a
self-insert for for david lynch kind of
wide-eyed about the world and
if you compare their haircuts at the
time they pretty much had the same hair
same thing with um
same same thing with uh david cronenberg
right
i mean
when you know he used uh
jeremy irons in was it dead ringers he
i mean it looks like david cronenberg
let's be honest right
um
so you see when filmmakers do this
sometimes i think they do it
subconsciously
but you're seeing i think it more and
more and it can be used to good effect
and um
you know i mean george lucas named the
lead character of his star wars saga
luke
kind of after himself luke lucas
you know
uh that could be argued
so self-insert i think as long as you're
aware
can work i think when it's done almost
to an exacting point um
i i don't know that it that it succeeds
every time
what if we just own our narcissism and
say okay i like to see myself on screen
like that well i think the very act of
thinking that someone would be
interested in a story that you thought
up in your brain
is kind of narcissistic to begin with to
think well
uh i have this idea in my head i'm gonna
make a film write a film make a film
produce a film direct to film whatever
part of the process you exist in i'm
gonna do that and then you're gonna give
me money to see this story
uh yeah that i mean look you have to
have sort of a healthy level of
narcissism but i think that needs to be
balanced with
self-awareness i think it's
absolutely critical that you have a
profound
self-awareness
to be able to balance that narcissism
and just keep it so it's it's not the
thing that dominates i mean
one thing i would uh if i could throw
some couple tips out to writers one keep
a blazer in your car
wherever you go you never know where
you're gonna be where throwing on a
blazer
whether it's a casual one like i have
now or whatever you just throw it even
over a t-shirt um it immediately
sort of ups your game right
some level of upscale casual the other
thing is i never go anywhere without
carrying notebooks
right so i always have a tiny notebook
very tiny that fits in the back of my
pocket
and i'll carry this notebook around and
i'll jot down ideas and it's better than
yeah i know we want to use the notes
function
in your phone no this is better there's
something about sitting there with a pen
and i always carry a pen the space pen
the space pen is in my pocket currently
oh great okay but this goes in my back
pocket and then the problem is um i
believe leading a creative life where
there are financial concerns you have to
balance two things one is you know
obviously being able to be creative the
second thing is being successful
from a business standpoint and that's
why you need a notebook that's a little
thicker probably like this
and
i hate to tell you this you're gonna
spend your creative time probably like
this and your business time in order to
succeed in the film industry a little
more like this notebook this is like a
a moleskin and i think
completely describes my sentiments for
dealing with that aspect of the industry
and where does um
everybody's narcissism fit into that so
they've got their blazer they've got the
two books the small one for creativity
the large one for business but then
we're all
narcissist in one way or another where
how do we balance that
uh you you balance that with being
humble
so that you keep that narcissism in
check but be bold
right and and that comes with asking
questions it comes with uh
relating to people and not by text and
not by social media posts i mean
actually talking to people
and i and uh
especially when i meet young filmmakers
today they
i just see that they haven't learned all
the lessons and they're maybe out of
balance
and the thing i see most often is just
relating to people one-on-one
face-to-face so
you know throw on a blazer or something
upscale casual that you feel comfortable
in
that represents you
and how you feel about yourself and and
and go out there and ask questions and
don't be afraid
don't be afraid to say hello don't be
afraid to say hi
uh don't be afraid to say hi if you run
into me i'll probably say hi back
and and we may get no conversations
probably because you know if if you meet
me in person you even know who the heck
i am
um you know we probably are into the
same things
movies is a great place to connect with
anybody
because who who doesn't like movies why
are you why are you watching me why are
you watching this channel
yeah i've had some great conversations
with total strangers after movies and
it's great i know i've said this before
but it's it's movies are a way to have a
conversation about anything
anything in life
so
be fearless about having those
conversations and keep your narcissism
in check i i'll say just like
when it comes to people i've met in the
industry people at the highest levels
i'm talking about major
celebrities superstars
are the most humble people i've ever met
and then it's generally the people that
are sort of trying to claw their way to
the top that that you see are kind of
having that
that that struggle with their own ego